this slow-moving jellyfish is
surprisingly hard to track
its home the ocean twilight zone lets in
very little light but houses plenty of
organisms
the creatures who live here are
constantly on the move drifting up and
down to hunt and avoid predators
but it's tough for scientists to observe
these stealthy ocean dwellers without
disturbing their migration patterns
most underwater vehicles emit light and
sound which can cause camera shy animals
to flee
and their equipment can only operate for
a few hours without human input
not nearly long enough to observe the
slow daily migrations
that can take over 24 hours to unfold
new research presents an underwater
robot that has captured these elusive
movements
and its creators think it's a big step
toward illuminating life within this
murky ecosystem
mesobot can follow marine animals for
over a day without disturbing their
environment
its array of sensors and advanced
tracking system lock
onto targets following single organisms
without a human taking the helm
it's not just a fancy camera taking nice
pictures of sea creatures
mesobot could provide key insights into
the earth's climate
the migrations of animals in the ocean
twilight zone have a major impact on the
carbon cycle
as co2 in the atmosphere dissolves in
the ocean surface-dwelling plankton
transform it into organic carbon these
plankton are a perfect snack for
travelers from the ocean
twilight zone when they return to their
home in deeper water
they release waste trapping the carbon
deep in the ocean
this carbon elevator takes up to 6
billion tons of carbon out of the
atmosphere
every year by tracking the movements of
twilight zone dwellers
mesobot could study these important
patterns helping unveil these dark areas
of the ocean
you